thank you very much uh I'm really
thrilled to be here at pycon or Pi data
I'm not sure
and introduce you how how
um we made the switch to polars a
lightning fast data frame library and
for those of you who already listened to
Nico's talk before there will be quite
some redundancies but I hope you can
benefit from my past perspective as well
and it will be a little bit different we
talked before so I will try to cover
things a little bit differently
so how come I speak today about polar
Studio it was around the end of 2021 I
think that I first heard of polars and
I'm not sure if I can fade here but I
think it's an inclusive place so let me
confess my first data science language
love was our
and
I really love the plier and tidy verse
and when I tried polars I felt right at
home
um because I never got warm with pandas
so I guess it's a bit quite the opposite
of Nico when he titled raised by pandas
um so for me it's
I was raised with deplier
so the opportunity to try it in a real
project that it Rose in May last year so
a year ago when we started a new project
and it was actually time series project
so we had the question before so I can
say yes it works for time series it
works quite well we do this project at
better call ports my employer where we
sort of complex business problems with
custom software data science and machine
learning for our clients
so let me introduce the team for the
machine learning part of the project
so first there's Tobias it he's a senior
software engineer with better call Paul
since about two and a half years and he
was already experienced with pandas in
Python 2 and then there's Dennis
recently graduated he works as a
software engineer at better call Paul
and he had some experience with Partners
in Python but I think it was one of his
first customer projects and finally me
I'm leading the data science and machine
learning practice for better corporal
so when we started the project
how did that go so I showed Tobias my
experiments that I did with polars and
he loved it straight away
and I and he was really Keen to do the
project uh with polars instead of pandas
but to be honest I was hesitating
I thought not to new and we don't have
enough experience with it and I was
afraid that it might end up as a big
burden for the project
but at the end what convinced me was
kind of a luxury situation and that was
our part of the project was not that
critical for the final solution delivery
and I said yeah let's do it and let's
give polos a try and close my eyes and I
hope that everyone would wait
um so of course everyone who talks about
polars talks about Speed and Performance
and how fast it is and we would say
later how fast it is for us and but my
primary motivation was actually
different it was the Simplicity of the
API
and performance really came second
so what I really like about the API is
that it is built around a simple
consistent grammar
and
most of our feature Engineering in the
project
builds upon these seven verbs that go
get most jobs done and those of you who
know spark might find some parallels and
they're also parallels with pandas and
um
what do you have so we have this select
to narrow down we have with columns to
create or assign columns you can filter
you can join or merge for partners you
can do the group buying aggregation
stuff and of course you can sort the
data frame so how does that work in
practice let's get that into practice
so what we're doing is we're reading two
files sales transactions and articles
and then we will try to calculate the
monthly best selling products of the
Year 2019 just for the sake of the
example here so we would start with the
sales transactions we would create two
columns one for the year one for the
month and then we would filter on the
year to only have data for 2019 and then
we would join the Articles to get the
product code because that's not in the
transaction data and then we would Group
by the product code and the month and
sum the pricing information to get the
total sales and then this is something
magical that we use quite a lot in the
project and Nico told us about it before
it's like an internal group buy so here
we're filtering on the rows that have
the maximum sales
when you look at the month
and so this would give you a nice list
with the month and the product code with
the maximum sales and you can sort it by
month and you don't
so
as you can see this almost looks like a
SQL statement and indeed the polar style
of doing things is much more declarative
than the imperative style many uses in
pandas prefer
and another thing you might have noticed
is that I did not talk about indexes
and
I know a lot of people love Fitness
indexes and they certainly a powerful
feature but they are so the confusion
and can be really difficult in Long
transformation pipelines and I don't get
them
so I find myself constantly fighting
against the indexing system I'm I
constantly do reset index and group
buyers index folds because I don't get
how you do this
multi-index filtering and how you
remember on which position you are a
column you want to filter on is so in
Polaris it's different
there is no index
so in in the how does that go how are
you well in the project I guess we've
written thousands of queries and I'm Not
Looking Back I don't miss these indexes
at all
so another great feature are the
expressions and we've seen some of these
Expressions what are what are the
Expressions so expressions are used in
polars to to formulate how values should
be calculated
um this could be some something simple
like column A Plus column B
um what could be splice that string by
comma and return the last value of the
array that would be created and and we
saw them in action with this over a
statement and Max was also an expression
and I think I could give a complete talk
about Expressions but we have to keep it
brief today
so let me talk about how you can use it
to do custom composable expressions and
I will give you a concrete example from
our project that proved to be really
useful so our project is about time
series and we have a lot of monthly data
and with monthly data you have a
trade-off
so calculating with normal data is a
really pain because you have these
things like every month has a different
kind of days and you have leap years and
leap seconds and all kind of nasty
things that make calculating the
duration between two dates really
complicated and with monthly data you
don't need that complexity because you
can ignore the days and you can ignore
the seconds and it gets a really easy
computation
but dates are nevertheless useful
because we know what they mean because
if you only would have numbers that
would be cumbersome in the exploratory
part because you want to know is this
the data for August 2008 and not this is
the date number I don't know 50 237 so
that would not be useful so what did we
do
so we wrote a function that takes a date
or an expression so it's it might be a
string or an expression and it returns
another expression and what it does is
you can forget about this get call
expression that is only some syntactic
sugar and it would take the year and
multiply it with 12 and then add the
month and subject one and what this does
is exactly this stuff you get a number
and you can compare these two numbers
and two con two months are exactly one
number away from each other
so
if you want to calculate the difference
between two months
in months between two dates
you can use this expression function
that we declared before and create a new
expression month diff that takes two
dates the start date and the end date
and you simply subtract the two
expressions
and
this can be
used in your query
so to get the average product months uh
when some items were sold so how old was
the product you would simply take the
sales join the Articles Group by product
code and then you can use this month's
diff function straight away and you can
calculate the mean on it and you can
take you can put the Elias so you see
the
expression is composable and
this month div and this as year month
function you can put that in a utility
library that you can use internally that
you can share between projects and you
can Pi test it with unit tests and just
works fantastically
another powerful feature of Polaris is
called The Lazy evaluation and
as I already showed you polas
looks a lot like these declarative SQL
queries and a lot of performance can be
gained by exploiting this declarative
nature and this is done by optimizing
the query before executing it so how
does that work so on the left hand side
you can see standard query that will be
executed eagerly so police will read the
complete file and then it will um
uh count the numbers for each group and
then it will calculate the mean of these
counts so there's no optimization
happening and this kind of mean there
are algorithms
um that would be able to calculate that
online so it's not necessary to
calculate the counts first and then do
the mean you could do that online
so the first option
that can be done is what I call eager
loading lazy query so you would load the
data
you would do this for data that fits
into your memory and that you want to
reuse as well so you do the loading once
and then you can call Lazy on any data
frame which will hold the eager
execution so every statement after that
we only build up your query and your
query is not executed before you call
collect so once you call collect the
query will be executed another option is
to do lazy loading and query so you do
not load the file into memory you just
say I will want to use that file this is
being done by using scan instead of read
and the rest is as always so at the end
you call collect
and you would do this
um if
um your file does not fit into memory or
if you don't use it that much so loading
the whole file would not be necessary
and would be too much too much overhead
so now performance
how does this translate to Performance
there are prominent benchmarks we saw
some of them by H2O or tpch and that
would be normally shown here but I want
really to encourage you do not trust
these numbers and do not give too much
importance to these numbers do not give
too much importance to the numbers I
will show because that will be different
for you's case and for your data and it
always depends and but be reminded these
standard benchmarks they are simple
queries
and the maintainers of these libraries
spend a lot of time to optimize for the
queries and they put a lot of effort to
to have that small bar in the benchmark
so in your project it might be different
so I brought you a statement that is a
little bit
representative of what we do in our
project but it's I had to reduce it
because normally the queries are really
big and would not fit on on the slides
but
it's kind of Representative
um so this simple query for for these
example spans 32 million sales
transaction uh 100 000 articles 47 000
products and it's um it's determining
when a product was sold first so in
which week and on which day
so
um I ran this on my ordinary laptop this
machine right here Eco laptop 16
gigabytes of RAM I need to upgrade
and how does this look like so um
I I plotted uh a little bit the CPU
usage for you so this is what the polars
code looks like so you see all the eight
cores are used and
goes quite boom
with uh panels it's a bit different it
takes much longer and you see it mainly
uses One Core and this core is switching
so it's not fixing the core
um it switches between the cores
it's not quite nice
so how does this translate into into
timings
um for this particular query we found
philosophy five times uh faster compared
to pandas on a side note from our
experience you should really take care
before switching to the pi Arrow back
end
um it was almost two times slower for
this query and I think this connected
with this group by so I think they have
to work on the group by but I'm not sure
maybe people here know better
so you might wonder why the lazy
evaluation
um is not working as good as it should
well actually it's because I cheated
so this query would not run on my laptop
because this articles things contains a
lot of strings and my laptop flows with
all of the libraries
and so what I did I limited the columns
manually that would be loaded from the
file and this is exactly the
optimization that the lazy polars would
do so this is why we don't see any
performance gain here
so how does this look like when you
switch a machine so I did that we have a
node server an on-premise machine that
has some cores and quite a bit of RAM
and we normally use that for big
optimization problems
and how does that go so first pandas
you see that 67 number 67 that's the
green one
it will be done let's wait
sometime
yes it's done so this is bundles
this is polar Siegel
oh the the done was a little bit too
early that is not synchronized so you
see it uses all cores and then I think
that is the collecting phase when only a
few cores are working
uh might be an artifact I don't know and
so in lazy mode it's crazy fast just
blinks
so blink blink and it's done
so in in this example you can see a 10
times performance gain and that matches
our experience so for many workloads
that we use we get a five to ten times
uh performance gain
but you have to know two things here so
again your experience might be different
you really have to try this at home and
second
um the clear execution if if you paid
attention on this one is only 10 faster
than on my laptop
so 70 cores emitted the old server so
the cores are not really fast
but you have to watch out when you
choose your course and also there was
this question about how many cores does
it use you can limit that it's an
environment variable
so you should pay attention to that when
you choose your numbers and your
machines
so as you've seen the laser execution
can be really beneficial and one of the
great features of polars is that it even
makes it possible to process data that
does not fit into your machine's Ram so
to activate this out of core processing
it's really simple you just say
streaming equals true when you collect
and this will activate a whole different
line of execution
and you can even
process things that do not fit where the
result does not fit into your memory so
this would be the same pocket but I have
to warn you this feature is an alpha and
to be honest
I really would not recommend using it we
tried it it did not work really well I
got all kind of strange errors and hangs
so
um sit tight and watch what they are
doing maybe they will this will become
more stable my experience is you should
not rely on this right now so if it
works for you it's good but you have to
take care
so you might ask how much time we spend
learning all this new stuff because it
was new for us well it was not that much
I think we were quite productive of the
two or three weeks and a lot of things
we were
um
touching was not really that much
connected to Polar so when I did reviews
of the code
um
the classic things like don't use a loop
here vectorize the operational don't use
apply a function use the native
capabilities so things we would have in
a standard pendless project as well
so I think
all of this is more about do you know
how to structure your data and how to
create a query and not so much about the
syntax
because there's a really good community
and that was really helpful and although
polars is still not that established you
really rarely have to wait more than a
day to get an answer so there's this
Discord community that is really active
and you can ask your questions on stack
Overflow and you can even announce your
stack Overflow question on the Discord
Channel and people will respond right
away
however sometimes your issue does not
get solved on stack Overflow because it
is a bug or it's a feature that is
missing so how did that go
well
um
we did that project for a year and we
had four bucks
I think we have another book but that is
not tracked yet we're still figuring out
if it's a buck or not and these were
um fixed really quick two bucks were
fixed on the next day this third bug was
really difficult was a strange race
condition
where you had to execute the query a
thousand times and five times a thousand
would fail and the other other 995 uh
tries well would be good
but they fixed that as well
and we had two feature requests that
were also really fast to be implemented
and we have one thing open that is
debatable so I think it's a buck
or at least it's a valid feature request
uh Richie things differently he thinks
it works as it should
so the project is reactive how active is
it
you can see the numbers here they're
doing a release almost every week so
it's quite insane
we not pin our versions in in our build
Pipeline and I think we only had three
build breaks because of new versions and
that were easy fixes
um so backwards compatibility and
release speed work really well for us
um a thing that varies that I'm worried
about is that green bar over there
so this these are the commits of Richie
Wing uh the Creator and the super main
maintainer of this Library
so
while this library is really great and
I'm so thankful for him that he created
it it's also a little bit
I don't know it's a lot of dependency on
a single person so I hope that other
maintainers will join the project and if
you are into rust and Apache area you
might consider this because it's a
really great project
so Alternatives I really really love
polars but of course apart from penders
they are the Alternatives so
just a few words before we have to
finish this so of course there's Apache
spark which we use a lot in one of our
biggest data science projects actually
the server you saw is for debugging big
loads that we put on Apache spark but
the overhead can be a hassle if you
don't need that for everyday project so
another option is qdf
which also has insane speeds but it runs
on GPU and so if you would
buy a server that has these 640
gigabytes in GPU memory I don't know
maybe the graphic cards would cost you
100 000 I think only the graphic cards
so um this can be costly
and the new stars duct TB
honestly I don't get it that much
because you have to write SQL queries
with duckdb and I don't like these big
strings in my in my code it reminds me a
little bit of the 90s when I uh first
wrote PL SQL statements on Oracle
databases so our choice what is it to
sum it up so for single compute
workloads we would use polars any day
for distributed workloads we choose
Apache Spark
but what matters most
is the team at hand
and your knowledge and your it landscape
and your operations and customer
preferences so I can't stress this
enough personal preferences do not count
your team your customer your landscape
your requirements is what matters most
so should you make the switch I hope I
encourage you to at least evaluate if
polar should be inside your toolbox
thanks a lot for your attention if you
want to know more about me or better
call Paul this is where you can find us
and I'm happy to take your questions
thank you Thomas so there are a lot of
questions very active audience so the
first question is is there something
like a query explainer in polars yes
there is I'm not sure what it is called
you can simply call show graph or
something and you will get a explain an
execution tree you have to install graph
with to make it work but there is yes
okay would you choose would you choose
one default data frame Library as a team
or would you use both interchangeably
and EQ the cost of more difficult
handovers fragmentation oh you really
have to decide that with your team in
mind so depends a lot on your team do
you like switching what do people prefer
um so I think it's quite easy to switch
but check with your team
okay
a speed up from pandas at 20 seconds
using one chord to polar's eager at
eight seconds using 70 72 cores seems a
surprisingly small speed up yes
those long queries function look like
they are easy to write but hard to read
how did you document them
well
um
so I think it's a lot easier to read
than a lot of standard pandas code
and I think you just have to get used to
these things so my team is really used
to read these queries I think with
experience you just manage it it's not
so much about documenting so I think
it's really hard to document that stuff
of course it helps if you have the right
variable names and you made clear what
your intent is but at the end sometimes
you just have to go through the
statement and execute it part by part to
see what it's doing yeah
polar seems quite similar to Pi spark
what's the difference and when to use
one or the other so if you need
distributed workload your spy spark if
you don't use polas that would be my
simple solution if you're on one machine
polas can do the job if your one machine
is not enough
and you can't scale the one machine then
use Pi Spark
long queries are hard to debug test how
did you solve this using polars so as I
said so there's no no magic for that
which is simply copy the statement and
we execute it part by part and see what
it's doing
what's the benefit over duct DB postgres
well it's more than a SQL engine so you
remember these things like the
Expressions where you can compose
expressions and make a library of
Expressions I don't see that happening
with SQL statements okay I think we have
time for one more question
how much does using custom
transformation functions affect
performance and lazy evaluation it does
not because it's native so this is the
really cool thing because these custom
functions they are not executed like a
python functions where it's translated
to the native capabilities of polars and
so there's no penalty for using this
okay thank you Thomas thank you thanks a
lot